Bitte schön.
Ja, hallo guten Tag. Ich heiße Ivraimusta.
Herr Kirschchen.
Ich möchte heute mit Ihnen ein Aufnahmengespräch durchführen, bevor wir mit Ihnen über Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden sprechen.
Ich möchte allgemeine Fragen stellen und danach kommen wir jetzt zu Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Vogel. Martin Vogel.
Martin Vogel.
Genau.
Okay. Und wie adten Sie, Herr Vogel?
42 Jahre alt.
42 Jahre alt und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 15. Mai 1980.
15.
182 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß und wiege 70 kg.
70 kg.
Genau.
Okay. Sehr gut.
Und was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe seit ungefähr 3 Wochen eine Verhärtung auf meinem Hals.
Und ich habe eine Verhärtung an meiner Leiste.
Wo genau?
An meinem Hals.
Und an meiner Leiste.
Link oder rechte Seite.
Okay. Die Verhärtung oder die Schmerzen?
Ich habe keine Schmerzen. Nein, aber ich bin sehr besorgt.
Okay. Wir haben die Verhärtung begonnen.
Also ich habe ungefähr 3 Wochen eine Verhärtung an meinem Hals bemerkt.
Hier oben war das.
Als ich das passiert habe, habe ich gemerkt, dass da eine Schwellung ist.
Und danach war ich nach einer Woche bei meinem Hausarzt.
Der hat sich das angeschaut und gesagt, das ist nichts.
Das geht wieder weg.
Aber das ist nicht weggegangen.
Und jetzt habe ich auch zusätzlich eine Verhärtung an meiner Leiste bemerkt,
die genau so ist.
Und deswegen bin ich heute hier, weil ich Angst habe und besorgt bin.
Okay. Wenn Sie die Verhärtung bewegen, tut es weg?
Die lässt sich nicht bewegen.
Es tut auch nicht weh. Nein.
Und wie können Sie die Verhärtung beschreiben?
Sind Sie z.B. schteif oder flüssig?
Wie eine Bohne?
Wie eine Bohne.
Und wie viel eine?
Nur 2 bemerkt. Eine oben und eine unten in der Leiste.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber?
Manchmal. Manchmal habe ich das.
Das kommt und geht.
Bevor wir die Verhärtung bemerkt, haben Sie griebale Infektionen bekommen.
Ob ich vorher einen Infekt hatte?
Vorher habe ich nicht bemerkt. Nein, ich war nicht krank.
Nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Und haben Sie nach Schweiß?
Was meinen Sie mit nach Schweiß?
Zum Beispiel haben Sie die Unterwäsche wechseln.
Wenn Sie viel Schweiß und viel Schwitz dann unterwäsche wechseln?
Nein.
Okay. Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ich habe ungefähr 2-3 Kilo abgenommen.
2?
Ja, 2.
Und in welchem Zeitraum?
Also das weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Ich habe die Symptome seit 3 Wochen ungefähr.
Ich wiege mich aber auch nicht oft.
Also ich wiege mich jeden Tag.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stolgang oder bei dem Wasserlassen?
Ja.
Hat sich die Farbe ihres Strukturs verhindert?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Okay.
Könnten Sie das nicht bemerken?
Gab es in Ihrer Umgebung?
Haben Ihre Kollegen oder Ihre Familien mitgelegt?
Haben sie beschwerden oder nur wie?
Hab ich nicht gefragt, weiß ich nicht.
Könnte das was Schlimmes sein?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Sind Sie Arzt?
Ja, ich bin Arzt.
Aber ich brauche einen natürlichen Labordiagnostik.
Ich möchte danach ein Blut abnehmen.
Ich möchte alle Ergebnisse da sein.
Und entscheiden wir, ob sie ein schlechtes oder ein Krankheit ist.
Oder nicht.
Nur jetzt kann ich gute Aufnahmegespräch durchführen.
Danach entscheide ich.
Okay.
Nun würde ich mit Ihnen über Ihre Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Aber möchten Sie davor etwas hinzufügen?
Was meinen Sie hinzufügen?
Zum Beispiel etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie etwas ungewöhnliches bemerkt?
Oder haben Sie vielleicht etwas vergessen?
Also ich bin sehr besorgt.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe eine schwere Erkrankung.
Und deswegen möchte ich schnell eine Diagnose haben.
Und gab es Ihnen vorgeschichte wichtige Erkrankungen?
Nicht, das wüsste ich nicht.
Okay, sehr gut.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen?
Oder nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Ich nehme ab und zu Parastamol, wenn ich Schmerzen habe.
Parastamol.
Wie viele Milligramm kennen Sie?
Eine, eine am Tag.
Und wie viele Milligramm? Die Dosierung?
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Was noch? Parastatomol?
Nein, ich nehme nicht.
Sonst nehme ich eigentlich nichts ein.
Ja, okay.
Ich möchte nun nach Ihrer Familie vorgeschichte fragen.
Und leiden Ihre Vater oder Ihre Mutter an wichtige Erkrankungen hervorgehen.
Also, mein Vater hat Bluthochdruck?
Ja.
Ihre Mutter hat eine Schilddrüßel-Unterfunktion.
Die Schilddrüßel-Unterfunktion.
Meine Schwester hat Diabetes.
Diabetes.
Okay, lebende Eltern noch?
Ja.
Ja, okay, sehr gut.
Und wurden Sie schon mal operieren?
Nein.
Sehr gut.
Okay, haben Sie irgendeine Allergie oder eine Verträglichkeit hervorgehen?
Hausstop-Allergie.
Hausstop.
Und vertragen Sie, ob Getreideprodukte oder Milchprodukte?
Ja, und schon. Das ist jetzt keine Beschwerung.
Okay.
Und brauchen Sie Hervorgehen?
Nur bei Feiern oder so. Nein.
Ganz selten.
Ja, irgendwie feiern. Sehr gut hören.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Auch selten.
Selten.
Gut.
Und nehmen Sie bitte das nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, die jede Patientin stellen muss.
Und nehmen Sie Drogen.
Ich nehme keine Drogen, nein.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Und was machen Sie beruflich?
Was ich beruflich mache?
Ja.
Ich bin Chemikant.
Chemikant.
Okay.
Und, äh,
den Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin ledig.
Okay.
Und wollen Sie allein?
Ja.
Okay.
Und als letzte Frage.
Sind Sie stressaufjesetzt
bei der Arbeit?
Wie immer.
Immer stressen wir uns.
Nichts besonders.
Und, äh,
arbeiten Sie abends
oder
übertragen?
Ich habe ein Dienst.
Ich habe ein Schichtdienst.
Schichtdienst.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Deswegen?
Ja, eigentlich schon, aber in den letzten so eine Woche,
eine Tag, Wochen,
bin ich unruhig.
Und machen mir Gedanken.
Und, äh,
wie ist die Appetit in letzter Zeit?
Normalerweise.
Okay.
Haben Sie gereist?
Ins Ausland.
Hab ich im Ostland war?
Ja.
Ich war letztes Jahr im Sommer, war ich in Spanien.
Im Sommer.
Okay.
Herr Vogel,
ihr habt meine alle Fragen gestellt.
Und jetzt möchte ich
erklären,
was ich machen sollte.
Und ich möchte
jetzt
Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach
möchte ich
Blut abnehmen.
Und
ich möchte
Ihre
Nacken und
Rechte leisten.
Ultraschall.
Ultraschall durchführen.
Ja.
Und wenn die,
wenn die Ergebnisse alle da sind,
entscheiden wir,
was machen wir
sollen.
Was ist das für ein Ultraschall?
Ultraschall,
Ultraschall ist eine moderne Diagnostik
und
therapeutischer Massnahme.
Es ist eine strahlenfreie
schmerzfreie
und nicht invasive,
kurze Untersuchung,
eine Minute dauert.
Und
durch
mithilfe
von
Ultraschall
oder Sonografie können wir
Ihre
Bauchorgane
oder
Ihre
Dimit, Sombaz, Dilleeva
oder den Daum
genau
und
bei
manchen Fällen
die Diagnose
feststellen.
Und es ist
sehr hilfreich.
Aber ich habe keine
Beschwerden im Bauch, am Hals und in der Leistrat
Beschwerden.
Ja, und
können wir natürlich den
Nacken
in der Region unter Leisten
bewegen.
Sombaz,
die
die Charakter
die Feherung
ist.
Sombaz, es ist eine
Süste oder es ist eine
Sombaz,
aber
eine Lege
ist es
Sombaz, die Muskelverherrung
oder Süste oder es ist eine
Sombaz, Sombaz, Sombaz
es ist eine
eine Essunungprozess
dadurch
durch Limitiverkontographie können wir diese Beote ein.
Okay. Okay, verstanden. Okay, alles klar.
Muss ich denn heute hier bleiben oder kann ich für nach Hause gehen?
Sie müssen zwei oder drei Stunden hier bleiben.
Okay.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Jetzt brauchen Sie nicht kein Medikament.
Geht das von alleine wieder weg oder was passiert dann?
Ich kann nicht genau sagen, weil ich jetzt die Diagnose nicht feststelle,
aber wenn ich ausreichende Kenntnisse oder ausreichende Wissen sammle,
danach kann ich genau entscheiden und sagen.
Okay.
Dann warte ich jetzt hier, oder?
Ja, ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Warte schon, Kolleginnen oder Kollegen, andere Fragen?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in diesem Zeitraum in dieser Zeit,
drei Wochen Fieber hatten, haben Sie schon mal gemessen?
Ja, das kommt und geht.
Das war immer so 38, manchmal 37,5, manchmal habe ich auch 39 gehabt.
Das hat immer so eine Schwank, das war immer schwankend.
Okay.
Haben Sie bemerkt, kommen Sie wie in eine Reihe, also drei Tage ohne Fieber und ein Tag?
Ich habe nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Sie Yukreis?
Nein.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie seltener Alkohol getrinkt haben.
Seltener Alkohol?
Ja.
Diese, in dieser Zeit trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ich habe in den letzten zwei Wochen kein Alkohol getrunken, nein.
Drei Wochen?
Also ich glaube vor zwei Wochen, da hatte ein Freund von mir Geburtstag und da haben wir getrunken.
Ja, aber ich habe danach nicht mehr getrunken.
Nach der Trunken haben Sie bemerkt?
Das war vorher schon da.
Ich wollte Schmerz, Schmerz, Schmerz.
Okay.
Verhaltung nur heißt...
Und leiste in der Leiste.
Und rechte Leiste.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin müde.
Der Kollege hat mich nicht gefragt, aber ich bin in der letzten Zeit sehr müde.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen abgeschlagen, muss ich sagen.
Ich mache normalerweise Sport, aber momentan bin ich zu müde, um Sport zu machen.
Ich habe mich nicht.
Ich mache die Sachen.
Ich mache die Sachen, die ich mir gefragt habe.
Okay.
Ich habe mich ein bisschen abgeschlagen, aber ich bin müde.
Momentan bin ich zu müde.
Okay.
Ich habe mich in der Leiste geblieben, aber ich habe mich in der Leiste geblieben.
Ich habe mich in drei Tage geblieben.
Undulierend?
Wellenförmig, Sie haben gesagt.
Ja, das war...
Also ich weiß nicht, ob das wellenförmig ist.
Es hat keinen bestimmten Zeitabstand gehabt.
Also das war zweimal morgens, dann war es wieder abends.
Und dann war es zwei Tage nicht da.
Jetzt ist es wieder da.
Das hat keinen bestimmten Zeitungsreinfall gehabt.
Eine Patriante im Zeldorf gibt es.
Gleiche Fall, aber...
Okay.
Neue Fall in der Innenzeltur.
Prüfung.
Ja, FSB.
Ja, es ist gut, das macht er.
Ja, im...
Ibrahim hat...
Wir werden ablegen.
Und deswegen, diese Fall ist sehr wichtig, ich denke.
Ja gut.
Allah denkt getötet.
Ja, können wir anfangen?
Gerne.
Hallo, guten Tag Herr Oberath.
Guten Tag.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen,
die ich gerade eben im Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Und ich möchte über ihn berichten, war ich.
Gerne, ich habe Zeit.
Okay.
Es geht um Martin Vogel,
der 42 Jahre alt
und 5. Mai,
98 geboren.
Was hast du, 9?
1989, 89 geboren.
1989?
1980, ja, okay.
1980 geboren.
Und er ist 1 Meter, 70 groß
und 70 Kilogramm schwer.
Und er hat sich bei uns seit 3 Wochen bestehende
eine Verhärtung im Nackenbereich
und im rechten, im rechten, im Gynalbereich
vorgestellt.
Sind die gleichzeitig aufgetreten?
Wie tun Sie bitte?
Sind die Schwellungen gleichzeitig aufgetreten?
Ja.
Er hat eine...
Im Nackenregion eine Schwellung.
Als eine Schwellung bemerkt.
Und die Verhärtung ist wie Bohne.
Es ist steif deswegen.
Und entferne klackte er über Fieber bis 38,
bis 39, 30
und abgeschlagenheit
und in Somni-Wegenbesorgheit.
Oder?
An.
Ja, wegen...
Und er außer dem...
In Somni bedeutet, dass er gar nicht schlafen kann.
Ja, dann.
Aber er hat Schlafstörungen wahrscheinlich, das meinen Sie.
Schlafstörungen.
Das sind die...
Ja.
Schlafstörungen reicht aber auch aus, wenn man das sagt.
Aber können wir das Domni sagen?
Schlafstörungen.
Er wird kaum benutzt, eher Schlafstörungen.
Ja, Schlafstörungen.
Okay.
Schlafstörungen und er hat demek, dass er
2-4 kg abnimmt.
Abgenommen hat.
Okay.
Und die Frage nach Schweiß
und Obstpation
und die Erwürfe wurden bei den Patienten verneint.
Und er nimmt nur paracetamol,
einmal am Tag bei Bedarf.
Bei Bedarf.
Und er...
An vorheren Erkrankungen
ist bei ihm keine...
Er hat keine Vorerkrankungen.
eine Püportreose bei der Mutter und eine Diabetes mellitus bei der Schwester.
Er ist bei ihm Hausstoffallergie bekannt und außerdem hat er keine Allergie und Beträglichkeiten.
Er rauf selten und trinkt Alkoholselten.
Die Frage nach Brockenkonsult wurde bei den Patienten vernein.
Er ist chemisch und ist ledig, hat keine Kinder.
Er wohnt allein und er lebt allein.
Er ist bei der Arbeit stresslos und lautet meine Verdachtdiagnose.
Er hat in zwei verschiedenen Regionen Verhördung.
Leistenbereich und Nackenbereich deswegen.
Haltsbereich.
Nacken und Halts ist das andere.
Oder Sie können einfach sagen Servikalbereich.
Also ich würde gar keine Diagnose stellen von Ihrer Stelle.
Sie müssen überlegen, Sie haben noch gar nichts von diesen Patienten.
Sie können Diagnose stellen.
Er hat eine Lymphadenokratie.
Sie können nichts sagen.
Sie haben alle Fragen gestellt, die Sie stellen mussten.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob der Patient Haustiere hat?
Nein.
Haben Sie gefragt, welches Sexualpartner der Patient hat?
Ob er wechselnde Sexualpartner hat?
Haben Sie gefragt?
Nein.
Diese Fragen mussten Sie zusätzlich stellen.
Aber eine Frage für die Moninik-Böse ist umgebungen.
Richtig, zum Beispiel.
Diese Fragen mussten Sie zusätzlich stellen.
Sie mussten genau die Fragen stellen, die man bei einer Lymphadenokratie stellen muss.
Das sind nur einzelne Beispiele.
Sie haben nicht alle Fragen wahrscheinlich gestellt.
Sie müssen die Diagnose stellen.
Sie müssen die Diagnose stellen, weil eine Lymphadenokratie alles sein kann.
Es kann aber auch nichts sein.
Deswegen müssen Sie sich ruhig halten und sagen, ich habe die Diagnose einer Lymphadenokratie.
Jetzt möchte ich diese Diagnose machen.
Okay.
Aus dem Belut möchte ich
eine große Blutbild.
Ein großer Blutbild.
Kennen Sie den Unterschied zwischen klein und groß Blutbild?
Was ist das genau?
Das heißt, der differenzialen Blutbild.
Differenzialen Blutbild und kleines Blutbild.
Wir müssen hier bei diesem Patientin, weil wir eine Lymphadenokratie haben,
einen differenzialen Blutbild machen.
Also eine komplette Differenzierung der weißen Blutköpfe.
Was ist der Unterschied?
Kleines Blutbild haben Sie hemoglobim, zum Beispiel mit MCV,
MHCV und MCH.
Okay.
Bombozüten.
Und Sie haben Leukozüten.
Okay.
Aber bei differenzialen Blutbild haben Sie die Aufgefahr.
Differenzialen Blutbild haben Sie die Aufgereiht.
Eosinophil, Basophil, okay, und so weiter.
Granulozutten und so weiter.
Nicht nur Leukozüten,
nur Detaillierte Leukozüten.
Differenziat.
Eosinophil, Basophil, Monosil.
Genau, ein differenzialen Blutbild müssen Sie machen.
Okay.
Ein solches Parameter.
Leberwerte.
Ja.
Und Detimea.
Okay.
Weil die bei Lenfvadenapathie
die
ist,
wirb die
Leukostöle.
Detimea erhöht.
Und Leberwerte,
Nier- und Werte.
Und Chemieblut möchte ich.
Chemieblut.
Und
natürlich
Blutausstrich.
Nicht Blutausstrich.
Nein, Blutausstrich.
Blutausstrich.
Okay, und
Wichtig ist auch LDH.
Ja LDH.
Ja, Laktat, Laktat, den Drogenas.
Genau.
Und Danach
ist es ein
Schittrösenwerte.
Ja, es ist sehr nah
Schittrösenwerte
und Verhörterung.
Deswegen möchte ich ein Schittrösenwerte
Schittrösenwerte
Welches ist denn das?
TCH,
TCH, TCH, TCH, TCH, TCH, TCH.
Warum ist
die Schittrösen
Untersuchungen auch wichtig?
Nicht nur wegen der Erkrankungen,
warum?
Wofür braucht man die Schittrösenwerte
wenn man den Patienten im Krankenhaus hat?
Weil die Region
Nein, wenn Sie eine Kontrastmitteluntersuchung machen mit CT-Torax zum Beispiel,
und Sie möchten Kontrastmittel geben, dann müssen Sie gucken oder ausschließen,
ob der Patient eine Überfunktion hat, eine Hypertereosa, dann dürfen Sie kein Kontrastmittel geben.
Warum? Wenn ich wenig vertreiben darf?
Das ist eine Schädigung der Schildgrüße kommen kann.
Hypertereose Patienten dürfen keine Kontrastmittel kriegen oder Sie müssen vorher die Schildgrüße blocken.
Weil Kontrastmittel besteht aus J, deswegen?
Sehr gut, klar.
Okay.
Dann müssen Sie vorher die Schildgrüße blocken zum Beispiel, ja?
Ja.
Ich möchte die Luftmotorstation abtasten im Servikalbereich und Leistungbereich.
Alle, nur nicht zwei Regionen, möchte ich die andere Luftmotorstation abtasten.
Die Konsistenz, die Größe und die Charakter von Luftmotoren möchte ich beurteilen.
Danach möchte ich Sonografie durchführen und gegebenenfalls ein CT mit Kontrastmittel veranlassen.
Vielleicht möchte ich einen Röntgenaufnahme im Lungen veranlassen, weil...
Was machen Sie vorher? CT oder Röntgen?
Röntgen. Zuerst Röntgen, danach CT veranlassen.
Was noch? Was alles, ich glaube?
Wenn der Patient eine servikale Lymphadenopathie oder Lymphzerklonsergrößerung hat,
sollten sie auch den Halsnasen Ohrenarzt konsultieren.
Der Hals sollte auch mit schauen, auf jeden Fall.
Ja.
Die Fahrrings, Larrings, alles mögliche mit anschauen.
Das ist ganz wichtig.
Können Sie denn so ein bisschen die Lymphknoten mal beschreiben?
Was ist gefährlich, was ist nicht gefährlich?
Die große ist über 5 cm.
5 cm?
Oder 5 mm.
Alles, was so größer als 1 cm ist, muss man aufpassen.
Ja, es könnte gefährlich sein.
Und multiple Lymphknoten, nicht nur eine,
multiple Lymphknoten, könnte es gefährlich sein.
Und es ist nicht beweglich, nur feste Konsistenz,
ist es gefährlich.
Und was noch größer Konsistenz kann sein?
Schmerzhaftigkeit, Toiletten.
Schmerzhaft oder nicht?
Wenn die Lymphknoten schmerzhaft sind,
ist ein gutes Zeichen.
Aber wenn die Lymphknoten nicht schmerzhaft sind,
ist sie sehr gefährlich.
Und schlettes Zeichen.
Und jetzt ist es in 3 Wochen aufgetreten.
Ist das gut oder schlecht?
3 Wochen, ich glaube, ist das schlecht.
Ja, weil wenn die Entzündung prozess ist,
ist eine sehr kurde Zeit.
Ja, und wir haben hier das Problem,
das ist nicht lokal, es ist auch woanders aufgetreten.
Bei den Patienten war es so, dass es zuerst im Zervikalbereich war.
Und dass der Patient später bemerkt hat,
dass in den Influential Bereich ist.
Er war ja beim Hausarzt gewesen.
Ich habe eine Vergrößerung, der Hausarzt hat gesagt,
da ist nix, geht nach Hause, das geht wieder weg.
Aber es ist nicht weggegangen.
Der Hausarzt hat gesagt, da ist nichts gehen nach Hause, das geht wieder weg, aber es ist nicht weggegangen.
Es hat dann noch einen Ingenieurbereich gemerkt und es ist besorgt und geht ins Krankenhaus.
Man kann das auch als Derb bezeichnen. Derb.
Eine Derbekonsistenz, Derb, D-E-R-B.
Das heißt, derb.
Das heißt, es ist sehr hart. Also es ist keine weiche Konsistenz, sondern eher so eine harte Konsistenz.
Eine beste Konsistenz. So kann man das auch bezeichnen.
Derb.
Beide als Patentgeschenke hat welche gesagt nach Schweißfragen danach?
Er hat nicht gesagt, dass er nach Schweiß hat. Er hat gesagt, nicht möglich. Also hat er nicht.
Schweiß oder keine Schweiß?
Keine Nacht Schweiß hat er nicht gesagt.
Wie ist Symptomatik? Nur Fibar und die Lirende.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Und ein Fatig.
Genau, ganz wichtig. Hier geht es nicht darum, eine Diagnose zu stellen in diesem Beispiel,
sondern um die Abklärung einer Lymphadenopathie.
Herr Oster, jetzt haben Sie Blutabnahme gemacht, Blutausstüch gemacht.
Sie haben den Patienten untersucht, sie haben CT gemacht.
Sie haben einen, was kommt danach?
Ein Röntgen gemacht, was kommt danach?
Ein Probe entnehmen.
Eine Probe entnehmen, okay?
Ja.
Eine Probe, oder sagt man etwas anderes?
Biopsy, oder?
Eine Biopsy, ganz genau. Eine histische und zythologische Untersuchung.
Ja, zythologische Untersuchung.
Biopsy, wie können wir sagen, wir mögen ein Biopsy entnehmen, oder?
Den Patienten oder dem Arzt?
Bei dem Arzt.
Ja, also das kommt ja nicht so fort.
Das kommt erst später, wenn der Patient stationär bleibt.
Und sie haben durch die Röntgen- und Blutuntersuchung,
durch die Sonografie und keinen wegweisenden Befund.
Sie wissen es nicht ganz genau.
Oder sie haben eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Sie haben eine Fein-Nadel-Aspiration.
Aber meistens machen die keine Fein-Nadel-Aspiration,
sondern die machen eine Exterpation.
Die nehmen den Lymphknoten komplett raus.
Es gibt einmal die Fein-Nadel-Aspiration.
Sie gehen mit der Nadel da rein.
Okay?
Fein-Nadel-Aspiration.
Sie gehen mit der Nadel in den Ultraschall gesteuert da rein.
Okay?
Und dann ziehen Sie mit der Nadel etwas raus.
Aber meistens nehmen die Chirurgen direkt eine Exterpation.
Die schneiden das auf, nehmen den ganzen Lymphknoten raus.
Ja?
Das ist eine Exterpation.
Ja genau.
Was ist das?
Direkt eine Entfernung.
Eine Entfernung.
Genau.
Okay.
Und wie können wir sagen, teilweise Entfernung?
Macht man eigentlich nicht.
Man macht sofort alles raus.
Und entweder macht man eine Biopsy, also eine rein
und Biopsy nehmen, oder man macht die Exterpation.
Okay.
Es gibt zwei Verfahren.
Wie ist das?
Es gibt auch grob Nadel.
Also Fein-Nadel bedeutet eine sehr dünne Nadel.
Und grob Nadel ist eine große Nadel,
wo man komplett ganzes Gewebe rausnimmt.
Bei Fein-Nadel kommen einzelne Zellen raus.
Bei grob Nadel macht man eine kleine Inzision.
Also man schneidet kurz rein.
Und nimmt die Nadel und nimmt der Gewebe raus.
Okay.
Welche Differenzialdiagnosen kommen Ihnen denn so in den Kopf?
Sie haben gesagt Leukämie, sie haben gesagt Potschkin.
Was noch?
Es ist eine Infektion.
Es könnte Infektion sein.
Es könnte普通 sein.
Es könnte mücglos sein.
Zum Beispiel.
Was noch?
Es könnte eine Autiimmuneckrankung sein.
Es könnte eine Metastase sein.
Metastase sein.
Akterädeinfektionen sein. Es könnte eine Sarkoidoso, Tuberkulose sein. Wenn der Patient eine Katzen hat,
zum Beispiel, könnte es auch Toxoplasmose, Brutzelose, alles mögliche sein. Es könnte also
parasitäre Infektionen sein. Man hat vergessen zu fragen, wo denn sie vor kurzer Zeit geimpft?
Imf aller Nese haben wir vergessen, ist auch ganz wichtig. Ja, lufen sie nicht vergessen.
Wo denn sie nicht vorgeimpft? Wo denn sie letzter Zeit geimpft? Es kann auch sein, dass das durch
Medikamente verursacht ist, haben sie gefragt, ob er neue Medikamente bekommen hat.
Ja, Phedetorien macht das zum Beispiel, Antieapoleptiker kann das machen. Wie er gündet
gefragt hat, ob er exzessive Alkohol getrunken hat, zum Beispiel.
Der Patient hat gesagt, Chemikant. Was bedeutet das?
Chemikant, genau.
Chemikant, benötigt ja Krankheiten.
Berufliche Exposition, ganz genau. Sehr gut, haben sie mit irgendwas Besonderes gearbeitet.
Könnte Lupus sein, Autoimmunerkrankungen, alles mögliche könnte das sein. Aber wichtig ist hier,
nicht die Erkrankung, das war meine Intention, sondern eine Lymphadenopathie zu diagnostizieren,
um zu gucken, welche Schritte kommen danach.
Und diese Patienten, die eine Lymphadenopathie haben, sind immer besorgt.
Die haben oft immer Angst, habe ich eine schlimme Erkrankung. Man muss die Patienten beruhigen.
Man muss sagen, wir sind ein erfahrene Team, wir werden alle diagnostischen Schritte machen,
um zu gucken, was sie haben.
Den Patient immer beruhigen und nicht sagen, wir müssen gucken, ob das was Schlimmes oder was
bösartig ist, das würde ich gar nicht erwähnen. Es ist noch zu früh, um zu sagen, ob es eine
bösartige Erkrankung ist, würde ich gar nicht sagen. Ich würde sagen, es ist zu früh, um
eine Diagnose zu stellen. Wir müssen als Team arbeiten, wir müssen diagnostische Schritte
einleiten, so etwas in Art. Okay, danke. Gibt es Fragen? War jetzt etwa ein langes Thema?
Unsere Patienten in Düsseldorf, in Dolente, in Dolente Lymphnoten,
unterlierende, vier Wochen, drei Wochen, und drei Wochen, und drüberholt, nach dem
Alkohol-Konsum, in Dolente Lymphnoten gibt es.
Ich meine, derулиs Diagnose ist einen non-höchsten Lymphon.
Könnte sagen, ja.
Dafür schieb ich einen indolente Lymphnoten, nachdem Alkoholkonsum schmerzhafte Lymphnoten und Gebišferlus,
bei Symptomatik.
Könnte aber auch HIV sein, ne?
Könnte auch HIV sein.
Ja, ne.
Der Patient ist jung?
Ja.
Und ich?
Ich.
Wir wissen nicht ganz genau, ob er HIV haben könnte.
Ja.